yeah it's quiet there and it is getting
very dark here in Miami you can you can
literally see and you hear the wind pick
up a little bit now you can literally
see the bands where it's dark and then
lights and then we see again more to the
south fill those lightning strikes that
keep coming in as Irma draws ever closer
Irma is drawing comparisons to a
category 5 storm that hit Florida in
1992 and that is Hurricane Andrew that
storm cut across the states causing 61
deaths and 27 billion dollars in damage
one of the hardest hit areas was
homestead 30 miles north of Key Largo
Elaine Quijano is in nearby Florida City
Jeff we're here in Homestead Florida
which is known as the Gateway to the
keys behind me in fact is overseas
highway also known as Route one and that
is the only way in and out of the
Florida Keys it is basically deserted at
this point no signs of any traffic on
Route one right now now irma is being
felt here just the outer bands not so
much with the winds which are not bad
right now but the outer bands are
bringing with it some severe lightning
and heavy rains we just had a major
squall
pass over and there is more red on the
radar headed our way
so the mentality here in Homestead right
now is that they hope they are safe but
they are very nervous many people
telling me that they feel this storm is
different than past one stuff